so it's been about a week now since the
whole will smith saga happen on sunday
exactly a week yeah can i let me ask you
a question so so a lot of girls remember
to be like you don't understand
he was protecting his wife he was
defending her honor right
and i said this to you and i'm like i
could understand that a lot of women in
their personal lives and their
relationships have felt abandoned by
their partners when needed most right
they felt like their partners didn't
have their back when they were being
attacked by other people not physically
but just like you know verbally or
whatever and they would have liked to
have somebody who has their back so they
see this incident like that's somebody
who has their partners back and that's
beautiful i can understand a bit of that
logic behind it okay but so it's twofold
first off you have to imagine let's say
it's you a regular person and your
significant other goes and hits a
comedian who says a joke about you while
they're on stage there's a fight that
breaks out cops get involved your
significant other goes to jail
for
assault do you still think that's a
beautiful act do you think that's a
wonderful thing that they're going to
get a criminal record potentially lose
their job
life because they decide to
attack somebody doing their job he only
got it was it was only a beautiful
moment because will didn't get snuffed
you know
the the there's something very
fascinating you got to take care of your
beautiful moment on the ground
knock the [ __ ] out
that happens that happened to these
young flags somebody jumped up on stage
with him and he ended up knocking that
dude out the new went to jail
dc was just defending himself yeah
because the dude was coming out he was
like what's going on right now he's got
the lawyers and stuff like that and he's
got the connections he's going to be
able to avoid all that but for a lot of
poor people that's not the case and
we're fortunate it ends with a slap
because most dudes you go to slap them
in the face a lot more breaks up
afterwards
so
to me i'm like how do you view that as a
beautiful thing that you expect your
male partners to physically go after
somebody okay
who said something you didn't like
or that hurts your feelings also the
second thing is like you can't make fun
of somebody's wife
well all the times that you guys were
[ __ ] talking celebrities and actresses
for doing a bad job making fun of them
doing your little to the replies that
was somebody's wife what about
somebody's daughter
what about somebody's sister can you
talk [ __ ] to them
no you can't if you think about it
everybody's somebody to somebody you
can't talk about somebody's mom that way
someone's daughter someone says every
woman is somebody somebody
can we say anything about but only wives
what does that even mean
what does that even mean
you guys are acting like they took a
stranger some random person no she's a
famous person she's a celebrity who does
movies
a joke was said about her can we no
longer joke about women in general
now you can abba you can
but
if some [ __ ] happens afterwards well
some [ __ ] happens i think it's such a
sad i think it's such a weird reply say
it when something terrible happens
okay something that we all agree
shouldn't happen and your reply is well
[ __ ] happens
say it
so next time a woman gets assaulted
next time a woman gets graped
what were you wearing
it's the same thing because
you said something you deserved it some
[ __ ] happens really happen
it's the same as the same rhetoric
it's the same trait of thought same
train of thought
it's the same trait of thought can we
let me ask you guys can we say anything
about women in public period
yeah you can but something's gonna
happen to you
we can talk about men as much as we want
but women we can't talk about them
we equal but you can't talk about women
what are we talking about bro what's the
line
as long as someone feels disrespectful
you you can't control how someone's
going to react agreed we can't control
somebody's going to react does it mean
we have to condone it or say it's
acceptable or sensible or logical
we can't control someone's react what
happens if it's a schizophrenic person
who stabs you in the neck because you
looked at them you can't control
somebody's going to react
we're looking at irrational responses
and we're saying like yeah we're
justifying getting a kind of quasi-world
that's what a lot of people are doing
they're justifying it i'm just confused
i sit back and i look a lot of stuff and
i'm like
that's weird it is
big fan of chris rocks i'm not saying
i'm the craziest fan but i've always
liked his work
but will smith in particular i remember
living in ethiopia and having satellite
tv and i'd watch that [ __ ] all the time
so seeing him fall from grace like this
was especially sad yeah but it happened
it can't happen to anybody of us we
agree but it's always different when
it's your quote-unquote metaphorical
heroes you will yeah right because he
was like the beacon of like
representation like cool representation
a lot of ways for me growing up fresh
prince was a big deal for me it was a
big deal for me too that's how i learned
he's a symbol of that i don't think of
the other actors when i think of french
prince though they're all great it was
him
that made the show right so it's just
like seeing that it was so sad and you
know it was just funny also seeing like
it was like four years ago i was like
oscar so white this year was like [ __ ]
moments
and it's funny because chris the
transition chris rock had that bit what
the difference between black people and
[ __ ] yeah and that was the most [ __ ]
that was so goddamn let me know if you
agree with this i feel like um
this is more so the racial angle for me
i feel like with black men a lot of
times some of them have like very
fragile sense of masculinity i told you
that it's like the slightest offense is
immediately we go on the fisticuffs you
know what i'm saying because we we've
been we've been
emasculated just in our vocabulary
just in the way we use our vocabulary
where we talk about each other you know
what i mean just go just roll the
monologue the entering monologue of baby
boy remember that movie when he talked
about that yeah when you talk about that
house is a crib
everything's a baby boy everything
yo what up son
everything is the
masculine it's emasculating you know i
mean everything is like that and so we
always kind of have to prove the society
kind of puts us in the book and kind of
baby us in a way in a sense you know you
know like we don't know how to act and
[ __ ] so we always have to prove that we
ain't no sucker and it's like that in
the community we ain't no point when we
have to step up you know what i mean and
you know what i do that too
it's not not i'm not pointing my i'm not
pointing fingers at you whenever the
[ __ ] we have the thing with fresh air
fit i have to be like oh you want to
throw down
let's throw down i could have let that
[ __ ] go
but you challenged me
let's go what's really good although if
anybody would have challenged me i would
have done the same thing
and that's what i was not a black or
white or whatever thing you want to
challenge me i'll take the challenge but
then again it comes with that it comes
with traumas it comes with
[ __ ] been messing with me my
whole life so i'm like no no today i got
the possibility that i got time i'm not
letting this [ __ ] it's also partially
where you come from when you're from
poor backgrounds
you already know somebody come to step
to you you can't afford to be a [ __ ] no
because then they're gonna come again
they're gonna start coming back
it's like being it's like being robbed
all the time you know whenever yo yo
break yourself fool yo take your shoes
off yeah but then they're gonna come
back around and you go hey so that's why
they always tell you even if you've got
no money you got to still earn your
respect yeah you got to show that you
know so so there's that sense of it too
right i i agree with that 100 i think
there's a financial aspect to it i think
there's a racial aspect to it but i was
like well black folks is like
even the gay stuff like i say the whole
power [ __ ] like jokingly i think it's
funny yeah some [ __ ] say it seriously
yeah they don't even want to be
associated with that might like
limit their masculinity just absolutely
right so if you so will smith also
speaks about he's like i've always felt
like a coward my whole life he talks
about his insecurities with j jada and
tupac and all that stuff
what that looked like was deep
insecurity didn't it yeah that's what
that's exactly what it was and i can i
can understand the feeling that's the
thing
i can't understand the feeling i
understand that right cause it's it's
that it's been that at some point when
you grow up i grow up and i'm a kid and
and and
like i told you that's the thing that's
the word that
that's a word that was said to me all
the time because i was dancing because
whatever reason you know the hagwon
exactly so
so
you come up to a spot a point in your
life that has been said so much then
you're like
say that [ __ ] one more time
see what happens
say that [ __ ] one more time see what
happens you know and
that's why when we had the video i was
talking to about i understand well yeah
i don't agree
i know it's not the right thing to do
that was not strain
that was not protection
that was ego
straight up
that was a say that [ __ ] one more time
because of
all the accumulation
so and i understand that i'm not saying
it's right and we all got a [ __ ] but
when you get in the position that's why
whenever you get to a position you see
how the effect that it has
to do that in 4k
and 4k
that's exhibit eight
[Music]
straight up so here's the other side of
the coin go ahead
even though i think what he did is wrong
i think you and i can both agree there
are circumstances that if somebody was
joking enough
you're probably tired to slap that
[ __ ] in the face
so let me give you an example context is
different context because skeptics is
different
context is different so here's an
example
him making those contact those comments
in the context of a comedy show or a set
at an award show where your job is to
roast people as you have been doing for
the last decade at these award shows got
no problem with it shut the [ __ ] up and
own your take the joke on the chin
now if a [ __ ] roll up on you on
the street and start talking crazy like
that i think that's a bit different do
we all agree context you get what i'm
saying if you roll in with your family
members your significant other your wife
your kids your your brothers or whatever
and somebody come and talk [ __ ] to you
in the street for no reason talking
about amy bit you bald isn't that i
think slapping them most of us would
agree we get it you don't come back i
get it i won't even hold you
but i'm not gonna encourage it
come on hi hey
hey
if it's my kid and you talk crazy to my
kid i wouldn't like like i said i i
wouldn't promote it but i know what i
would do at that time and i would
definitely more not in courage because i
don't know what's going to unfold after
that you know what i mean but yeah i get
it but you have to understand people
context is very important yes it's
important in a joke it's important in
some things that you say it's important
in everything and how things are said
context is the common denominator for a
lot of things for if things are good or
bad so the context of we're joking
there's a lot of ways that you're gonna
handle this
and i guess it's a lesson for all of us
yeah it is a lesson for all of us it's
not just you know it's cool to point
fingers at this and that and be like yo
this is wrong and [ __ ] like that but my
daddy always told me whenever you point
your fingers at someone remember that
you got three three fingers pointing
back at you that's why i always point
like this but that's that's a different
thing i digress yeah today people have
convinced themselves that their feelings
matter more than anything
that because they feel something
everything is justified thereafter she
felt really hurt by the jump does
[ __ ] know she got alopecia does
she know that it's a big thing she
struggles according to risk rock he
didn't know even if he but she felt some
type of way so it's justified does that
make sense to you guys that somebody who
doesn't even know you have a condition
makes a comment what if you're just
swearing hey [ __ ] [ __ ] and this person
doesn't know you got tourette's like man
you you being rude and like
disrespectful right now they don't know
you guys don't even know what tourette's
is they think you're just screaming
you get to punch them in the face they
don't know what you got going on and
let's keep it a stack
everybody saw jada's bald head and she
hadn't said something she's like
jada feeling special today whatever you
got a nice head to be bald go ahead
you know i mean so i just
i just can't understand how you sit
there and you're like well you feel some
type of weight if you feel hurt
everything's justified afterwards
because you feel hurt everything
afterwards is sensible
what about the other person's individual
who may not know about what you're going
through were they being completely
negligent in that or is there some
reason that they may not know what
you're going through
you having a bad day great that doesn't
entitle you to be a big piece of [ __ ] to
people you feeling terrible doesn't mean
you get to go punch folks because if it
did bro there'd be a lot of violence in
these streets right now a lot more
every time you had a bad day someone
said something to you it could set you
up you get to punch them in the face
but that's how folks are justifying
things it's crazy to me and this is also
like the same thing that says like yo
punch a trump supporter punch this you
don't like somebody's opinion it makes
you feel some type of way you don't like
who they support what candidate you want
to engage in physical violence like it's
crazy to me
how willy-nilly we've gotten with some
of this stuff oh it happened and guess
what happened
guess what happened yeah some people
died and someone had to defend himself
his name is conrad in the house that's
what happened
someone was not agreeing with him being
there with a firearm they chased him and
tried to take his firearm away
and try to hit him with a [ __ ]
he didn't have i think it's more
complicated that that specific situation
but here's an example i'll give you i'll
give you go ahead they published uh some
some article i believe this was in
chicago saying like a lot of the
violence over there stemmed from
arguments on facebook somebody would say
something they didn't like or post a
pitch they like they go up in the
streets they shoot them up over things
that are said they felt slightly
disrespected they think boom if you
disrespect me i can't let that [ __ ]
stand yeah i gotta kill you okay
i gotta kill you
does that seem sensible that's crazy
this is the next evolution though of
these kinds of feelings right definitely
it was just she was just practicing
protecting his own honor it was just
protecting his honor when did we go
medieval on this [ __ ] turn the knights
in armor and [ __ ] take my glove off slap
a [ __ ] [ __ ] and then after that yo
let's go
we're going in this treats
anyways let us know what you guys think